on est en plein coeur de paris les
restaurants sont soit fermées soit
réalise de la vente à emporter l'appel à
la désobéissance civile et à l'accueil
des clients en salle n'a pas vraiment
été entendu et peut-être que la dernière
sortie fut du ministre de l'économie y
est pour quelque chose
les restaurateurs qui ouvre ne
bénéficieront plus du fonds de
solidarité pendant un mois
et s'il ya récidive ils le perdront tout
court et ce fonds de solidarité il faut
savoir qu'il s'élève à dix mille euros
par mois ou une indemnisation de 20% du
chiffre d'affaires de 2019
dans la limite de 200 mille euros par
mois forcément cette annonce de bercy
elle a donc quelque peu douché les
espoirs de rebellions de certains
restaurateurs mais pour d'autres il est
imprudent et irresponsable d'aller
contre l'interdiction acté pour lutter
contre le coc vie de 19
c'est le cas de valérie gérante de son
restaurant
et parce que l'envi lui manquait elle a
mis le couvert et service des clients
atypique vous avez pu croire aux gens
que vous allez vous allez ouvrir
aujourd'hui parce que entre les coups de
fil et clients sur place vous en avez du
monde veillées ça j'ai pas fait croire
j'ai juste repro fit et du petit écran
de lumière qu'on me donnait pour pouvoir
faire passer mon message c'est à dire
juste remettre un petit peu de vie dans
mon restaurant sans faire prendre le
danger à personne voilà redresser des
tables
et voilà m m juste en scène une chaîne
de restaurants où on reste positif
moi je sais que j'essaye de travailler
un petit peu
avec ma clientèle qui est génial et qui
a ses fidèles donc je fais un peu de
vente à emporter à son au moins basée
sur notre chiffre d'affaires donc c'est
beaucoup plus réaliste c'est juste pour
me comprenez que les gens soient
impatients de revenir manger au
restaurant
bien sûr bien sûr que je le comprends
moi même je suis impatiente comme eux et
bien évidemment c'est dans notre adn
d'aller au restaurant et dans les bars
enfin vie on est français on aime manger
on aime boire
donc effectivement je comprends
totalement que ça manque aujourd'hui que
vous aussi ça me manque terriblement
terriblement je rêve d'aller boire un
café je sais ce que je fais tous les
matins normalement je vais boire un café
en terrasse
là ça me manque beaucoup situation
intenable également pour eliès gérant
d'un kebab dans le 18e arrondissement
son établissement a perdu 70% de son
chiffre d'affaires depuis la fermeture
des restaurants
il y a plus de trois mois ce retour avec
le coverflow à 18 heures là je vois me
dis-je pharma 10 météores à partir du
18h confort commencé à travailler
normalement n'ont aucun partir de 18h
les gens ils sortent de leur travail
pendant et prendre leurs sandwichs et
ranches mais comme ça c'est dur c'est
vraiment dur des clients à la table d'un
restaurant c'est presque devenu de la
science fiction en cette période de
pandémie
des établissements qui pourrait pourtant
ne pas rouvrir de sitôt pas avant le 6
avril en croire nos confrères du point